foreign
everybody welcome back to flickers of
fear haven't done one of these in a
minute and this is a movie that I
actually had been wanting to see for a
while and only just finally now got
around to
so HP Lovecraft
um there have been a lot of adaptations
of his work not as many as Poe
admittedly
um and I'm gonna say that adaptations of
HP Lovecraft stuff is kind of Hit or
Miss I feel like um you know I guess
that's probably partly because you know
the the kind of brand of cosmic horror
that he's known for is kind of difficult
to effectively render on screen I guess
so I feel like some of the best
lovecraftian it's quote-unquote films
tend to be ones that don't necessarily
adapt an existing story of his but kind
of just work within the Mythos that he
created right
um you know because I would consider
movies like uh the thing or the mist or
the void or the endless or in the mouth
of Madness maybe I would consider those
lovecraftian movies even though they're
obviously not based on any Lovecraft
stories
um but they still had the similar kind
of vibe to them that suggested the
larger themes that he usually wrote
about now that said there have been
quite a few very decent films made from
lovecraft's actual stories but I've
noticed that the better adaptations tend
to be the kind of loose ones um you know
I'm talking about reanimator uh from
Beyond Dagon which kind of got bad
reviews but I actually quite loved it uh
the haunted Palace which I've reviewed
on here before and the recent Colorado
space which I actually really liked a
lot and I feel like this was also the
case with the movie that I'm going to be
talking about today
which was American International
pictures
1970 crack at lovecraft's short story or
his uh Novella actually from 1929 which
was the Dunwich Horror and this movie I
had somehow managed to never see it
before now like I'd seen the poster and
stuff like that and I was just kind of
like oh yeah I probably should get
around to that and I never really hear
anybody talking about it but I'm glad
that I finally did get around to
watching it because I've been wanting to
see it for a long time now reviews of
this movie uh both contemporary to when
it came out and more or less nowadays
too seem to lean kind of heavily toward
the negative and I don't really get that
um I find that kind of mystifying to be
honest because I dug it quite a bit I
thought it was really good now I will
say that the movie deviates somewhat
from The Source material it's close
enough you know if if you're gonna if
you're not gonna be a stickler about it
you know what I mean
um and I actually found it a really
entertaining uh movie in its own right
so the Dunwich Horror was produced by
good old Roger Corman uh and it was
directed by Daniel holler who actually
actually he designed sets for some of
corman's Poe films which I really love
and he also directed another Lovecraft
adaptation back in 1965 which was called
die monster die which was actually kind
of loosely based on the color out of
space which I mentioned earlier
so this movie the Dunwich Horror
actually Stars a very young Dean
Stockwell which I thought was pretty rad
uh he plays Wilbur Watley and uh Sandra
d of the Grease song Fame uh as his I
guess like potential victim
now Sandra d it should be noted was
actually really happy to appear in this
horror movie here uh because the sort of
squeaky clean image that she'd kind of
become known for like while she worked
with universal was kind of beginning to
wear on her and she wanted to do you
know something that was a little more
substantive or something like that
because I kind of feel like the Dunwich
Horror I feel like um I think it was her
first quote-unquote adult film well not
it's not doesn't like porn but like
adult as in because before that she'd
kind of been known as like a child actor
and like a teen star and stuff like that
so this was like her first grown-up role
I guess so at the beginning of the movie
um this actually has a really cool like
animated credit sequence like I really
really liked it and then we see kind of
like a bit of a flashback scene I guess
um to a woman giving birth now those
familiar with the original story will
probably recognize this as the you know
this event that's happening as the birth
of Wilbur waitley and his twin brother
if we want to call it that
so we then jump ahead a bit to the
character of Dr Henry Armitage uh he's
played by Ed Begley I believe this was
his final film role and he has been
giving a series of lectures about like
local history and the Occult and stuff
like that at good old miskatonic
University in Arkham so it's at this
point in the movie where we're
introduced to both the Necronomicon
which Dr Armitage is in the process of
returning to the library because he was
using it for his lecture and Dr
armitage's student whose name is Nancy
Wagner who's played by Sandra Diaz I
mentioned earlier now she wasn't a
character in the original story but I
think she makes like a nice addition to
the story here so not too long after the
book is returned to the library
it's kind of mysterious but sort of
intriguing young man comes into and
asked to look at it now the Librarians
are like bro it's like almost closing
time uh you can't just show this
Priceless book to any old Rando who
wanders in the place but eventually he's
able to talk them into it uh
particularly after Nancy seems to take a
little bit of a shine to him I guess so
it turns out that this dude is Wilbur
waitley Who I've mentioned earlier is
played by Dean Stockwell uh the role was
initially supposed to go to Peter Fonda
but I guess he couldn't do it for
whatever reason but I really like Dean
Stockwell in this role at first he seems
just as fascinating a fellow as a girl
could want really I mean uh I'm gonna
say that this is incidentally a pretty
big departure from the original Source
story uh in which Wilbur was described
as pretty much like a stinky charmless
goat man type thing but um I actually
didn't mind the change for the movie it
kind of made the character of Wilbur
seem more more dangerous I guess because
he looked normal like handsome and
Charming even
um so he could therefore kind of like
blend in which made it like all the
easier to do like all his little
nefarious Deeds or whatever so Wilbur is
in the library and he's just spending
way too long studying the Necronomicon
the like Librarians are like we would
like to go home at some point tonight
you know jerk um so he gets kicked out
of the library by Dr Armitage and he's
at Dr Armitage has actually heard of the
weightlies and he just doesn't have
anything good to say about the whole
entire family but Wilbur is actually
able to ingratiate himself with Nancy
but he could they kind of go for a drink
and then he's like oh no I missed my bus
you know what I mean it was that kind of
situation I had no idea what time it was
Bloody blah and she's like oh no now you
won't be able to get back home she's
like I'll give you a ride which of
course is what he was fishing for the
whole time
so she gives him a ride back to his
creepy old farmhouse in Dunwich
and she gets persuaded to stay for a cup
of tea reluctantly but then she's just
kind of like oh why not uh and of course
he drugs drugs it he also like goes out
and [__] with the car so she can't
leave but the stuff in her drink
actually seems to just make her like
just more compliant because the next day
um she seems perfectly willing to just
stay with Wilbur like indefinitely she's
just like I don't want to leave we're
just hanging out it's cool this drug
also kind of gives her these weird
dreams in which she's kind of being
chased and then overwhelmed and sort of
it's actually assaulted sometimes it's
not real clear
um by this big group of like naked
rejects from burning man is kind of what
they look like so even though Wilbur had
implied that he lived at this house
alone Nancy is actually quite startled
to find that old weightly who's Wilbur's
grandfather he's played by Sam Jaffe he
lives there as well and he's pretty uh
cantankerous let's put it that way so he
even tries to get rid of Dr Armitage and
Dr armitage's uh or actually Nancy's
friend Elizabeth who I guess is like
another student they come out to the
house to check to see where Nancy went
because obviously she didn't come back
and they're just like well that's
mysterious like where the [__] did she
go so they went out there to like check
where she went
but I mean Wilbur's magic or drugs or
combination of the two things I guess uh
is pretty strong I guess because Nancy
just insists that she's staying there
for own volition and she was 100 not
being roofied into this [__] so go away
Elizabeth uh rightly is super suspicious
though and after she talks to this local
physician named Dr Corey and his nurse
who's actually played by Talia Shire I
immediately like I saw her in the thing
and I was like that's tally Shire but
yeah she's actually this was an early
film role so she's actually still
credited Natalia Coppola in this but it
is definitely her so Elizabeth uh talks
to them and then she decides she's going
to go back to the weightly place and
like warn Nancy that she's in danger and
try to get her the [__] out of there
because like the doctor and the nurse
tells like yeah there's all kind of like
weird [__] going on out there at that
Farmhouse unfortunately for Elizabeth
though
she goes into the house and opens the
wrong locked door I guess and ends up
getting devoured by some thing uh which
is kind of made up of quick flashes of
color and like maybe some hints of
tentacles and things like that uh this
thing whatever it is busts out of the
room that it was locked in and then kind
of starts going on a rampage so
meanwhile Dr Armitage discovers that
Wilbur's mother Lavinia has been
confined to an asylum since the birth of
her twins and also finds out that even
though Wilbur's twin was supposedly
stillborn that was the story anyway the
other creature that Lavinia spawned is
still very much alive and now is
presumably on the loose so Wilbur's
whole plan for this uh is to bring his
father uh who's the old one Jag safaf
into the world I guess like via Nancy's
drugged up womb I guess because she's
like a virgin right and this was
apparent certainly what lavinia's
purpose was but Wilbur figured out like
that was what his dad was trying to do
like trying to bring them in but it
didn't like work out
um or at least as far as Wilbur is
concerned he's just kind of like I think
it didn't work out because Lavinia was
an unwilling incubator like I'm gonna
get it right this time because I've
magically made Nancy like totally
compliant with my wishes so now this
time like yagsathoth will come through
successfully it didn't work out too good
last time now at some point prior to the
main festivities where he's gonna try
and bring the old one through old
weightly the grandfather dies kind of um
accidentally on purpose kind of
um because he's not really wanting to go
along with Wilbur's plans right and the
townsfolk also get uh mighty peeved when
Wilbur just waltzes into the local
Cemetery with the body like in the
middle of the day and tries to bury the
old geezer in the family plot which I
mean it is their family plot but still I
mean there are laws you know what I mean
uh Lavinia also dies in the Asylum like
subsequently she's like muttering in
some weird language like as she dies and
then also as she dies like there's all
of these but this real unsettling like
birds screeching that they kind of talk
about you know that's they're coming to
get her soul or something like that
shortly after this Wilbur's twin which
was the monster thing like locked in the
room obviously he's causing all kind of
Destruction in Dunwich and kills a bunch
of the locals and all of that kind of
stuff
um I I'm gonna say I actually really
like the way the movie showed the
monster like I said this is a very very
low budget it's American International
pictures you know what I mean I mean in
the original story the thing is
invisible and it sort of is in the movie
too although you can kind of track its
passage by like they make the um the
grass in the bushes like you can see
this like this wind kind of going
through there and there's like all of
these kind of like various
like posterization kind of effects like
with all these different colors like
like posterize flashing and stuff like
that and it's kind of like we were
watching it it's we were like I would
really hate to think that anyone who
watched the movie and wasn't familiar
with the original story thought that
Roger Corman was just cheaping out by
making the monster invisible because hey
I mean you don't need a monster suit or
anything like that but so it's very
budget friendly
um but the monster was invisible in the
original story so they weren't just
cheaping out they were trying to keep uh
you know keep to this period of the
story um and I really think that they
did do a decent job with the way that
they showed it so the weightly house
actually burns down like soon after that
and then Wilbur takes Nancy up to
um this kind of like uh it's called
Sentinel Hill and it's got this thing
called The Devil's Hop Yard which looks
like an old uh you know sacrificial
altar type situation so he's got her
laying on there like all sexy and
willing
and then it's implied that he rapes her
though it's all done like through
suggestion like Sandra d was pretty
adamant that she wasn't going to do any
nude scenes I think they did do a few
quick like boob shot like nipple shots
and stuff like that but I'm not sure I
was her I'm like assuming that that was
probably a body double so yeah so he
does all of that and it would appear
that yag sathoth is going to come
through like be born through her baby or
whatever but then at the last minute Dr
Armitage who like I said was kind of an
expert in the occult right he shows up
and uses kind of like some counter
spells to ostensibly send the old one
back to whatever Dimension he came from
so we actually get a brief Glimpse at
this point of Wilbur's monstrous twin
who was the one that took after his
father as everyone says um and this
actually looks pretty cool like I said
it's this big like tentacled kind of
thing like up in the sky it's all like
posterized and stuff and then it just
kind of like vanishes you're led to
assume that Dr Armitage is spell like um
send it back or whatever
um and then at one point because the
universe is mad I guess like Wilbur gets
struck by lightning catches on fire and
just falls off like a nearby Cliff like
right into the sea and I was just like
man somebody hates you bro so all's well
that ends well right
um not so much because as the very
groggy Nancy is kind of being helped off
the Altar and down the hill they're sort
of like this overlay image that shows
that she's already got this big ass
fetus like sprouting inside of her so
the viewer is led to assume it's like oh
my God what unspeakable horror will
you know be will emerge from her
previously virgin loins you know what I
mean so as I mentioned I thought this
was like a really solid adaptation of
the Lovecraft Story I mean yeah they
made a lot of changes like they
drastically changed Wilbur's appearance
um they added the character of Nancy and
the whole bringing yagsatha four through
a virgin womb angle which wasn't exactly
the way it was in the book and they
altered
sort of the original plot point of this
monstrous twin growing larger and larger
until it like essentially took up the
entire weightly Farmhouse like they had
to keep building it out building out
because it kept getting bigger and
bigger and they didn't really put that
in the store because like I said it's
for Budget reasons probably
um I have to say too that Wilbur gets
killed a lot earlier because I think
Wilbur he's not as Maine a character in
the story as he is in the movie you know
what I mean like he's a main character
but not the way that he is because he
gets killed like pretty early on in the
story like I think he just gets like
mauled by a guard dog or something like
that so he has like a pretty ignominious
like death I guess
um but honestly I think like the changes
kind of only serve to make the you know
the story more cinematic so I think they
were largely successful ones
um I also really liked Dean stockwell's
performance as Wilbur like he came
across as like really kind of handsome
and charming and sort of beguiling at
first even though that you knew that he
was up to like some Sinister [__] like
you weren't just entirely sure what it
was
um and Sandra day was good in this too
like because I feel like she was sort of
channeling her previous like child actor
teen actor like her innocent Persona
into this kind of wide-eyed hapless uh
naive character that she was playing now
admittedly she wasn't super proactive
and she always had to have like her
bacon saved by other people she was so
she was essentially like a damsel in
distress but I mean in her defense
Wilbur was drugging her and or using
Magic on her to force her to do what he
wanted so it's not like she really had a
lot of say in the matter so yeah I mean
I don't think this is necessarily the
best Lovecraft adaptation out there but
I think it's like a pretty damn good one
I don't really understand why it has a
lot of negative reviews because I really
enjoyed it quite a bit
um so I really recommend it to anyone
wanting to see a fairly accurate
representation of the story or I guess
like at least one that sort of captures
more the spirit of the material if not
the exact letter of the story you know
what I mean but out of all the Lovecraft
adaptations I definitely think this is
kind of like a top tier one so that will
do for this flickers of fear hope you
enjoyed it please remember to like share
and subscribe and all of that kind of
business and I will see you again on the
next one bye